[Música]
y Paraguay Ya entró en la recta final de
Cara a las elecciones presidenciales
unas elecciones que según las encuestas
muestran un resultado muy reñido entre
los candidatos Y en donde hay en juego
varios temas cruciales para ese país
suramericano en directo América los
ponemos en contexto Quiénes son Entonces
los candidatos más opcionados para
llegar a la Silla presidencial Pues
estamos hablando de Santiago Peña de la
asociación nacional republicana O
conocido en ese país simplemente como
partido Colorado que es un partido
tradicional de la escena política
paraguaya también está Efraín alegre
quien representa al partido liberal
radical auténtico que se presenta a la
vez con una coalición llamada
concertación nacional también disputa la
Silla presidencial paraguayo cubas por
el CN que es el partido Cruzada Nacional
euclides Acevedo del movimiento nueva
República y José Luis chilavert del PJ
que es el partido de la juventud que es
reconocido mundialmente por haber el
Arquero de la selección paraguaya de
fútbol cerca de 5 millones de ciudadanos
paraguayos son los que están llamados a
votar muchos de ellos lo harán
preguntándose es necesaria una
alternancia en el poder en Paraguay
poner fin a décadas de dominio político
del partido Colorado eso lo decidirán
los votantes el próximo domingo entre
los retos que tiene el próximo
presidente que llegue a gobernar ese
país pues está el completo despegue de
la economía paraguaya después de la
pandemia del covid 19 también la lucha
contra la pobreza porque según el
Instituto Nacional de estadística de ese
país la pobreza afecta al
24,7% de la población es decir estamos
hablando de cerca de un millón 800.000
personas que viven bajo la línea de la
pobreza también la lucha contra la
corrupción hay que decir que Paraguay
está en el puesto número 137 de un total
de 180 países en ese listado entre los
más corruptos en el mundo de acuerdo a
reportes que presenta la organización
transparencia internacional también la
lucha contra el narcotráfico que ya es
un problema prácticamente común para
todos los países de Suramérica y también
el posicionamiento de Paraguay dentro
del mercosur dentro de la región
suramericana y también en el mundo darle
un poco más de visibilidad a ese país en
la escena internacional el domingo 30 de
mayo France 24 estará dando cubrimiento
a las elecciones presidenciales de este
país con enviados especiales a la ciudad
de Asunción para informarlos sobre esta
jornada electoral y posteriormente
tendremos el análisis en un programa
especial y también en el programa el
debate